hey what's up my name's Samuel leaves
and even though I'm a young guy I've
been in property now for over a decade I
bought my first house when I was 17
years old started from scratch
working-class humble beginnings now I'm
a multi-millionaire I own lots of houses
all over the UK I also own a castle
Rivard house I build houses from scratch
I teach people how to invest in property
I've got a construction company so I'm
doing very well financially but here's
the interesting thing I just really
enjoy sometimes going undercover and
being like an undercover millionaire I
wear normal clothes I live a pretty
normal life so I do challenges where I'd
start again from scratch I meet people
did crazy things and if you watching on
YouTube you'll have seen some of the
crazy challenges that I've done over the
last couple years started again from
scratch gone to America with no money
I've lived in people's houses that have
had nothing to tried to work with them
so here's what's happening right now
I am planning on doing another big
challenge for you guys on YouTube and I
want you to think about what you want me
to do you tell me to do it if it sounds
like a good idea
I am crazy enough I have the time I will
just do it so in a comment below what
crazy challenge
do you want to see me do property
related finance related maybe undercover
I don't know what you want me to do for
comment below because I'm open and I'm
itching to do a new challenge so I'm
gonna plate right now I'm gonna put some
of the footage from some of the old
challenges on hopefully that will give
you some inspiration and give you a bit
of an idea about the kind of thing I
enjoy doing comment below your ideas and
I will do it I'm working for 70 leads
you know you're gonna be in this
documentary you're gonna be like dude
the voice of wisdom throughout I need to
be disguised this is crazy what do you
think one number just falling now
people seem to like rent rooms all the
time it's not safer I'm glad we had an
uber driver that not understand property
what's going on here if we pull this off
though I think it will be it'll be a bit
of a miracle he's got ten of these
houses is a lot to do that's impossible
perfect candidate excuse me would you
want to go ahead the doors open really
all these are stages in the area oh my
goodness oh I want to film as much of
this as possible to show you guys take
away all that stress I'm just trying to
work out oh my goodness look at this in
this city
then I suck because oh I'm so strong man
I definitely sir this better not go in
the documentary about to go to a village
where we install the water tanks and
it's a bit early I think I'm behind
those cues are gonna get absolutely
destroyed man is this risque how do you
choose not bad I mean could be worse
could be way of water yeah okay so the
cheapest house is 130,000 pounds and
it's a boat
hey it's a long shot seems like in
London every hour is rush hour I think
we're gonna absolutely killing and stuff
but you don't need an office we just
walk into a Travelodge baby nice very
dangerous all I need is 4850 now this is
when magics gonna happen now 2:30 okay
stripping that's waiting for 500 pounds
a month how would anyone rent the 500
panel
there's no floor space this is horrible
and then leaves now you have to walk the
ABC then you figure out the X Y Z so
only them sign that friendly dinner
you really didn't but I'm sure I'll
charm in with my Midlands charm when we
get there and I'm here today to know
that policy if you only someone I always
feel like I'm in a dream lands I don't
even know what day it is I feel like I
need to process what's going on see
that's the thing as school is not a
building of schools the people I feel
better
I'll get free house that's how easy is
hi everybody
anyone can do this look at mine it's not
complicated just doing it
[Music]
thank you so much for watching the video
it's kind of interesting looking and
seeing some flashback of some of the
previous stuff that I've done really
really look forward to reading the
comments in the description and I'm
gonna be seeing what you want me to do
next
also can I just say real thank you from
the bottom of my heart because if it
wasn't for you guys for the subscribers
for the support the love the following I
wouldn't be where I'm at today so thank
you for subscribing and I really do love
you from the bottom of my heart please
subscribe if you haven't already over
here also if you want to see the
challenges the full challenges if you're
not seen them yet you can check out the
financial freedom challenges that I've
done right up here and of course if
you'd like to meet me and spend a couple
days with me at the property investors
crash course you can do that right here
thanks so much
peace out I'll see you next video